j'ai ici pour parler de résilience et
qu'elle ait l'air donc déjà vu six de
respirer un peu dieu un petit jeu que je
vais votre mémoire
de votre un petit jeu que vous avez dû
jouer en votre tendre enfance vue qui je
pense est pas si
vous avez vous joué à un moment ou un
autre à l'essai du rhône respiration le
jeu longtemps possible donc ça dure à
moins d'être à la piste du grand bleu je
pense que c'est pas facile qu'on le
pende d'entre nous de dépasser la
musique ça montre une chose déjà c'est
que les 15000 trauner qui passent
quotidiennement sur nos mouvements sont
vides au et donc que la pollution
atmosphérique à laquelle les verts est
devenu un sujet une préoccupation de
premier rang et malheureusement les
chiffres qui nous sont donnés
régulièrement par le n est notamment
l'annoncé 7 millions de personnes qui
décèdent chaque année dus aux effets de
la pollution atmosphérique ne sont pas
là pour rassurer 7 million de personnes
dont un peu près 60 % due à la mauvaise
qualité de l'air ambiant extérieur donc
cet extérieur il est clair que ne pas
agresser nos poumons via différentes
substances qui ne sont pas forcément
toutes surveillées sur le plan
réglementaire et donc les guerres que
les 700 à 800 millions de l'expiration
que nous allons devoir gérer tout au
long donc de notre vie vont être
affectés par cette qualité verts et une
par sept son évolution est donc tout à
fait normal
des quelques questions légitimes tout
d'abord qu'est ce que le bonheur que
nous recherchons il est clair que 11
chaque chose c'est une bonne qualité de
l'air ensuite c'est vert est il
réellement nos sous pour nous quel que
soit l'endroit où je me trouve chez moi
à l'intérieur proche les autres
situations proches d'activités
industrielles ou même éventuellement en
rase campagne donc finalement de d'où
vient son salem
mot apple esprits malins et enfin on
sait qu'il a les médiums qu'il ya un
lien entre la pollution à cautionner la
qualité d'air et donc la médecine
allemand quelle est sa reine a dû et
finalement comment réduire l'effet de
cette aire qui peut être de notre
cabinet sur ma santé donc en fait
essayer d'avoir une attitude de
résilience
alors moi qui suis un cinquantenaire
revient pas c'est qu'ils amendent et
résilience résignant késako donc là je
vais après ma formation donc de là diniz
se distinguer qui m'a permis de
retrouver le sens étymologique original
mais bien sûr
ingénieur chimiste on a surtout déjà lié
le
caractère donc lézignan en physique avec
notamment la résistance des matériaux la
fameuse es1 tm et donc c'est grâce à
cela que j'ai pu la prendre par exemple
que l'asim titanic la température à
laquelle il se trouvait était loin
d'être résigné donc arrête isolé pour le
côté professoral pour cette salle en
chine j'ai appris et également un bon
vieux principe unis en 1984 par bus le
chatelier qu'est le touch l'équilibré
chimique qu'ils étaient ici qui disent
simplement que lorsqu'on a un peu de
modifications en concentration dans
peinture pression un système en
équilibre cet équilibre mariage in il va
réagir fortement pour revenir un
équilibre en essayant de minimiser la
perturbation qui lie équipes du pôle
imposé donc ok donc ça on a aussi revu
résilience c'était un mariage vous
semblez assez logique mais bien sûr que
vous pouvez le voir comment on devait
vous présenter la notion de résilience
est aussi appliquée à des sciences parce
que plus douce notamment en termes de
psychologie pour le soutien en tête de
trouver 10 et le soutien psychologique
pour des personnes qui ont suivi à un
choc traumatique
excusez moi
donc est également écologique donc mais
écologie
c'est l'art est la science des relations
de l'être vivant avec son environnement
et donc cela on peut distinguer deux
types de résilience j'ai pu distinguer
deux types de résidente la résilience
écologique et la résilience en a généré
la résilience en écologique ça c'est
assez classique c'est la mesure de la
persistance
d'un écosystème a
réagi aux perturbations qui lui sera
posée tout en essayant de se maintenir
et enfin bien sûr la résilience ont un
génie c'est plus simple des plus général
qui se serait simple ou un traumatisme 9
5 qui peut ainsi dans vous avez génère
une situation qu'on vers lequel il faut
revenir à 7h en équilibre il cela le
plus rapidement possible ce qui veut
dire que quand dame j'ai compris que la
résilience arrêté un moment orienter
plus vers une leçon de court terme en
fait en termes de réaction du choc
des applications type les catastrophes
naturelles récentes ou s'éloignant d'un
petit peu de la notion de l'antenne qui
l ai pu s'associer au niveau des risques
une stratégie qui plonge - climatique ou
où il sera possible énorme c'est là où
on s'est plus orienté vers une notion de
curatif que préventif et donc c'est là
où il va falloir essayer de réagir et
notamment de se demander qu'est ce que
ça peut nous apporter aux mêmes de
résilience et qualité de l'air vraiment
quand on regarde les porter sur google
résilience et qualité de l'air on a on
commence seulement à 20 buts et cette
année le nombre de publications assez
importants mais on voit leur domaine qui
est en plein essor tout simplement si on
peut essayer de résumer le mode de
fonctionnement les gens ont d anvers est
centré sur une carte plus grandes
fonctions que sont l'alimentation la
production le déplacement et se récréer
les plus jeunes se divertir donc ces
fusions sont interdits pendant 13 et
bien sûr elles auront un effet et seront
affectés par la pollution atmosphérique
est automatiquement se baladent sur ne
va induire une pression économique et
sociale qui va être une réponse de
l'argumentation une réponse
également on a construit gagnaire qui
elle même va venir un impact sur les
fonctions et donc par effet de
domino sur la pollution atmosphérique et
donc d'écrire que ces différentes
modalités vont être affectés par le
problème de cathéter est donc c'est là
le falloir les faire changer de façon à
tirer une permettre de peut-être plus
résilients et c'est là où la divers
champs d'investigation intéressantes
dans le domaine de la recherche
alors en n'oubliant jamais on fait de la
recherche scientifique ne jamais oublier
de bien définir quel est l'objectif que
l'on se fixe pour pouvoir vraiment un
mauricien vite qu'ils soient interprétés
et surtout
compréhensible donc si on regarde le
problème de la qualité de l'air force
est de constater qu'on est en train de
changer de modèle on a un modèle qui
nous a été induit dans au début des
années 80 par les directives européennes
il ce modèle est dans une change et du
moins il a atteint ses limites notamment
on a une approche cloisonnée par pau
lons qui tient absolument pas compte
d'un effet qu' en effet le cocktail dans
la qualité vers donc dans l'air que nous
respirons et ça c'est un ballon en juin
un reproche qui nous ait eu de la part
des spécialistes de la santé on a
également que le fait de se tourner vers
le bon vieux trio non coupable désigné
que sont le trafic les industriels et le
résidentiel là encore c'est un minable
sur un enchaînement qui est insuffisant
on fonctionne à l'heure actuelle pour la
semaine la vérité n'est rien une
comparaison d'un indicateur avec
différents sun dont la conclusion est
loin d'être évidente au public qui vous
parle de valeurs cibles valeurs limites
doubt l'écart pour ce n'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui ait jamais
reçue compréhensible de la part du
public home a également cette notion de
pertinence de l'indicateur cet
indicateur selon une mesure il mesure de
quoi une concentration massique cette
concentration massique en un polluant
donnée qui n'est pas forcément un
polluant au goût du jour cet indicateur
malheureusement n'est pas suffisant là
encore aux yeux des spécialistes de la
santé et enfin javel malheureusement
pour terminer c'est que l'addition
l'image donc collé dans les années les
années ancien de pouvoirs publics de
l'état protecteur et
bien lire même malheureusement est
providentiel malheureusement est un peu
hip hop et c'est là justement où il ya
une nécessité de prendre en compte donc
les synergies entre la qualité de l'air
et son évolution et des problématiques
sont nettement plus globale et
confortable par exemple les problèmes de
nuisances olfactives les problèmes
d'allergies dues au pollen en ce moment
parce que certains d'entre vous de le
ressentir des virus des rédactions font
ce que thaksin par diverses recettes
et enfin le changement climatique et
dias à la notion de précarité matisse en
tout cas il est clair que cette relation
résilience est câline rbs estime
collaboration de tous les acteurs et
quand je dis tous les acteurs c'est les
citoyens l'établissement mais j'aurais
oublié les scientifiques avec plein de
domaines dont désignant les domaines de
la santé les sens deviennent les
industriels et ne pas oublier également
les médias qui sont eux-mêmes des
transmetteurs d'information et ce à une
voix qui a des nouveaux concepts tels
que l'explosion jalal sayah en français
expo logis où les citizens confiance aux
citoyens sauf citoyenne ou participer en
tout cas ces nouveaux concepts ne pas
oublier on est scientifique ces
scientifiques de s'appuyer sur une
méthodologie
une rigueur scientifique donc qui est
basée sur une méthode et donc qui va
asseoir une crédibilité des résultats
l'on voudra
alors si j'ai à résumer quelques effets
de
potentiel de recherche l'un des premiers
intéressant intéressant même si c'est le
pouvoir de ces mesures la capacité
des particules donc un polluant qui est
relativement en tête de gondole les
médias donc décrire les antioxydants qui
sont des éléments test monuments
naturels donc de notre système de
défense moore se demande réagir à toute
alliance et ça c'est un très bon moyen
d'évacuer le stress commence très fort
qui est un mécanisme vieux vitesse qui
est liée à des phénomènes de pathologie
cardio mais ce cas précis comme la
chaîne humaine de l'europa league
bronchite et même s'il fait un demi
siècle ce principe il est assez simple à
ce jour et encore les tables cérébrale
c'est à dire un prélèvement une adam bon
spécifique qui nous permet donc aux
sites de tirer des conclusions notamment
de certaines pathologies vous avez ici
sur votre droite l'examen de particules
de sable saharien qu'on a connu et les
appels ou des classements et halo 3
des pollens nantua sont en plein dedans
plein boom en dehors à cause des
conditions atmosphériques
donc ça c'est un premier élément est
seul mad world automatisation de ce type
de procédé est une voie de recherche
donc qui est assez onéreux
autres aspects qui touchent plus il
dirait un texte qui veut nous aider à
mieux nous comporter c'est une sont les
micro capteurs ou système nerveux je
pense que la plupart
rassemblement tenu poids minime entre
connectés qui leur permet peut-être
d'avoir souillé leurs serviettes même
l'impression après air ben vous avez une
discussion officielle nécessaire
capteurs telle qu'elle a été définie
récemment notamment par la semaine on
voit que ce système un puissant
automatiquement fait sur cette
définition c'est ce concept un lieu
automatiquement elle joue ce qui y est
relativement facile à dire et à mettre
en oeuvre
autonome donc facile d'accès notamment
dia le marché sony donc vous pouvez
acheter des indicateurs sur
sur internet où vous pouvez même le
fabriquer des médias a dit un tutoriel
donc disponible sur ce genre qui veut
d'être désigné en nombre large c'est
intéressant mais il faut pas oublier que
ça va être de falloir une associée à un
concept de traitement de données d'un
nombre massif de données et cette notion
d'assimilation de donner la psyché
intéressant pour notamment tout ce qui
est la partie seul bruit de machine
learning voire même l'intelligence
artificielle art par contre il ya peu ce
type d'outil il va donc assimilés révélé
c'est très séduisant contenir le
bellegard qu'une couleur se marier
encore faut-il qu'il y ait un processus
de validation qui soit le guet russie de
vachement avoir des résultats sur lequel
complice vrai atc de l'intéressé bon
finalement en confusion des sculptures
et autres
c'est à ce prix c'est que les cavs qu'on
a le droit respire un air qui n'est pas
à notre santé ça c'est clair c'est
inscrit dans la loi et malheureusement
qui dit droit dit aussi de voir les saps
suivi de l'état de la qualité de l'air
va amener des devoirs et c'est la part
donc pour cette notion de devoir qu'il y
a du champ de prospection très
intéressant de la recherche pour pouvoir
élaborer des outils qui soit
relativement utilisable facilement
qu'ils soient surtout motivant pour ce
est simplement de voir les appliquer il
fit aussi puiss montré une efficacité
qui soit éprouvée et ça ça nous est
rarement très exactement en résidence
mais ça je dirais ça c'est un avis tout
à fait personnel s'est soumis à deux
conditions d'abord ils sont l'homme
arrête de jouer à l'apprenti sorcier ils
comprennent enfin que ne peut pas tout
contrôler et aussi que malheureusement
il n'ya pas de futur sans passer des il
faut en noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]